[Music]
welcome back to cbs mornings now at 7 30
britain's royal family faces another
potential scandal this morning police
are investigating allegations that one
of prince charles's charities offered to
help a wealthy saudi businessman get
official titles and even citizenship in
exchange for a donation the news of the
investigation follows this week in this
week's announcement that prince andrew
has settled a sexual abuse lawsuit it's
a twofer mark phillips is outside
buckingham palace for us
mark good morning
good morning well with andrew settlement
earlier this week the hope here at the
palace had been that there might be a
lull in the royal rolling drama but no
with this queen it seems if it's not one
kid it's another
i'm here
the queen stoic as ever has been trying
to get back to royal duties dispelling
rumors she might have coveted although
her leg has been acting up well as you
can see i can't move and the palace
seems stuck as well in a recurring loop
of trouble
this time it's charles the heir to the
throne is patron to many charities and
his name is an asset when it comes to
raising funds
but now the police have announced
they've launched a formal investigation
into whether a saudi arabian billionaire
was promised favors if he donated a
large sum to the prince's foundation
british citizenship and her honorary
knighthood were said to be dangled
before the potential donor an allegation
he denies
prince charles the palace says knows
nothing about that he doesn't get
involved in the day-to-day stuff
this man does or did
michael fawcett once the prince's valet
rose to become chief executive of the
prince's foundation and general
right-hand man
until he resigned late last year when
the alleged cash for honors story hit
the papers the police inquiry is
expected to focus on him but the
investigation does not reflect well on
prince charles either i think he's
regarded as pretty arrogant and pretty
out of touch paulie toynbee is a
newspaper columnist and not a royal fan
i think there is a sense that he really
is of another era and he has very much
seemed like somebody on another planet
the concerns of this planet have been
dogging another of the queen's sons
prince andrew he may have avoided an
embarrassing court battle by agreeing a
settlement with virginia dufrey who had
accused him of sexually assaulting her
when she was a teenager but while andrew
denied the charges he has agreed to pay
what's assumed to be a multi-million
dollar settlement and now people are
wondering whether he's got the spare
cash or whether he'll have to ask mummy
for help
there is a rising chorus here that if
the queen does bail him out it must be
shown that the money comes from her
private funds and not from the public
purse
with andrews out of court settlement it
was also hoped here that the dust of
controversy would settle around the
palace but with prince charles now under
public scrutiny for all the wrong
reasons
it's not a good look nate
not a good look at all mark phillips in
london bark always has a good look i'm
knighting him right now in the studio
from afar best writer on television mark
that's right i'm just saying
right about now meghan markle looks
pretty spectacular
i'm just saying no doubt about it well
mark thank you so much